more than 300 ads for Donald Trump's
re-election campaign have been rejected
by YouTube and Google and it is a
fascinating situation and one that was
misreported to begin with there were a
whole bunch of headlines floating around
which made it appear as though these
were Trump ads that had been pulled down
but the truth is these were never
approved to begin with and it does
change our interpretation of this so
we've talked before about how Donald
Trump's behavior on Twitter does seem to
violate Twitter's own terms and
conditions because he's bullying people
he's causing dogpiling and targeted
harassment there's a really good case to
be made that Donald Trump's Twitter
account should be banned but it hasn't
been in the last few months I've been
getting more and more emails from
viewers saying you know David before
your videos on YouTube
I'm seeing a Trump ad and the ad is
often riddled with lies or it's
attacking individuals in ways that seems
to go against YouTube's rules or
whatever and of course I always explain
we don't have any control over the ads
but that people can report them to
YouTube if they believe that the ads
violate the terms and conditions we then
heard from YouTube CEO Susan Wojcicki
Wojcicki I completely I continue not to
understand how it's pronounced Wojcicki
but I guess that's how she pronounces it
I don't know she was interviewed on 60
minutes and she said that over the
summer 300 different Donald Trump ads
were not approved and they were not run
at all because they violated either
YouTube or Google's guidelines and
immediately as news started to spread of
this speculation was rampant about if
trump's ridiculous ads are mostly
allowed on youtube what was in the ones
that were so bad that youtube rejected
them CBS reviewed the documents and
realized we have no idea why they were
rejected we see that they were rejected
but we don't know why could it be
because the ads were telling extreme
lies or inaccuracies could it be that
the titles had bad punctuation or
grammar Google ads don't allow stuff for
example like all caps that's not allowed
but is it just copyright and
I believe that that's the most likely
thing there are lots of headlines that
are reacting to this as Wow
YouTube is willing to do what Facebook
will not do which is not to allow ads
that are targeted harassment not to
allow ads that are riddled with lies we
have no evidence that that's why these
ads were rejected by Google and YouTube
and the simplest and most likely
explanation is that these ads either had
some music in them that the Trump
campaign did not demonstrate that they
had the rights to because I'm sure they
didn't have the rights to it because
Trump regularly uses music at events
that he doesn't have the rights to or
that it was a grammar capitalization
punctuation thing that is actually
something Google is strict about the
lies are not really the problem there is
no reason right now to think that
YouTube and Google have done anything
different than what Facebook has done
about lies in political ads they've done
nothing Facebook has done nothing
YouTube Google has done nothing about it
Susan Wojcicki may knowingly be hiding
behind these reports since she knows
that the reports don't tell us why the
300 ads were rejected I wouldn't put it
past the Trump campaign to deliberately
submit ads they know will be rejected so
at some later point they can pull out of
their pockets the victim card and saying
oh our ads are being rejected its anti
Republican bias so we've got to be
really careful with these stories in
case in point the first headlines were
just wrong there was a headline that
said 300 Trump ads taken down it's not
true they weren't approved to begin with
takedown suggests they were public ads
something happened there was outrage and
the ads were pulled these ads were never
approved and number two the implication
that this was for content there's not
evidence of that as of right now most
likely this is for copyright issues
spelling issues formatting issues if we
play along with the false narrative or
at least the unsubstantiated narrative
that these ads were published and then
taken down for content which is not what
happened then that allows the Trump
administration to claim martyrdom and to
claim anti right-wing bias the reality
is they're not the Vic
here they're most likely benefiting from
the power of the bully pulpit just like
Trump has ignored requests for documents
and testimony and the like without
consequence
just like Trump regularly flouts the
terms and conditions on Twitter with no
repercussions whatsoever this appears to
be another version of the same thing
let's report what we know happened which
is simply that ads were not approved
let's not pretend to know why when we
don't and I would love to hear by the
way from Susan Wojcicki what it is that
YouTube if anything plans to do about
inaccurate and bullying political ads
because we're getting into the season
now and I'll be honest with you if
YouTube cracks down on inaccurate or
bullying targeted harassment political
ads the David Pakman show will make less
money what I mean by that is election
years are our biggest years historically
biggest growth and biggest what's called
revenue per thousand views why because
since we do news and politics on YouTube
more and more candidates start to want
to buy ads that will play before our
videos the way YouTube ads work is that
there's a sort of auction system where
when there's more demand you have to be
willing to pay more per time that your
ad is displayed because there's more
competition that price goes up and up
and up when there is a lot of interest
in politics like in an election year if
indeed YouTube were to crack down on
this it would be worse financially for
the David Pakman show but it would be
the right thing to do because this has
become so toxic and such a reliable
means through which misinformation and
disinformation can be spread that
something has to be done however the
practicality of it is extremely
difficult to imagine actually a handling
in a fair way which is why I understand
Twitter saying no more political ads I
mean if YouTube did that we might be out
of business but I understand why Twitter
took the decision that they took let me
know what you think the next video is
coming soon but before you go to that
please hit subscribe and like we're
running a test we believe that if
everybody does this this will hugely
boost us in you
oops algorithm and then everybody wins
I'll report back to you how this works
make sure before you go on to that next
video hit subscribe hit like thank you
so much